it's my pleasure today to introduce um
two speakers the first one i think will
be um rather brief but um is actually
joining us from the national bio
microbiome data collaborative
um as a representative and that is uh
pujao van gaay who's the scientific
community engagement manager
um and pujao is based out of or i should
say the collaborative is based out of
lawrence berkeley national lab she has a
phd in computational biology from the
university of minnesota where she
studied the impacts of migration on the
human gut microbiome and obesity
development so after she speaks then
we'll hear from dr lisa carson's who's
an assistant professor in um our
department and in our division so d mice
and bcb
also has a joint appointment in obi-gein
uh division of urogynecology and her
research is focused on methods for
robustly understanding the relationship
of the human microbiome to disease uh
she has a
really strong emphasis on methods of low
microbiol
microbial biomass to better understand
the urinary microbiome's role in
non-infectious bladder disorders and
over the last year she's been part of
the national microbiome data
collaborative ambassador program
so
there will be this is as was mentioned
in the um abstract there will be a this
is a precursor for a workshop that will
be hands-on dealing with
uh urobiome metadata and so there will
be a um link put in the chat for
workshop registration
um and obviously if you have any
questions you can do that in the chat so
i'm going to
hand it over now for this overview and
introduction to both dr van gaay and
then dr karstens
thank you shannon
um so today we'll i'm just going to give
an overview of today's talk we're going
to talk about the national microbiome
data collaborative and their mission and
then i'll go into a brief introduction
about the human microbiome and the
urinary microbiome or urobiome
then we'll go and discuss a little bit
about the data life cycle and metadata
what metadata are
and
how um
and what the existing microbiome
metadata standards are and how we can
adapt them for eurobiome research
specifically
i'm happy to jump in really quick to um
talk about the next few slides so just a
quick overview of what the national
microbiome data collaborative is so
we're a department of energy funded
pilot project um as uh mentioned already
we are based at the berkeley lab but it
is a multi-lab
effort so there's three other national
labs that are also involved with this
project
and essentially our mission is to make
multi-ohmic microbiome data more
accessible so um for many of you out
there who are working with multi-omic
data and it doesn't even have to be
microbound data specifically
i'm sure that you're all well aware of
the problem of trying to find data sets
that you're looking for from published
work and having to sometimes contact
researchers in order to access that so
we're really working on
making streamlining that process so that
you can come to one resource to look for
the data sites that you're interested in
so what that means is that we're
focusing heavily on standardizing the
metadata along the way
and then of course standardizing the
bioinformatics workflows that you use to
process the multi data and then of
course uh building out kind of this data
ecosystem and the infrastructure to
house all of that data
if you could go to the next slide
so just a quick snapshot of what our
data portal currently looks like so
again we are in a pilot phase so it's
not
you know very well populated yet but i
encourage you all to take a look and
explore um it's actually uh
let me just put it in the chat here
if any of you want to go ahead and
explore the data portal it is public and
you can um take a quick look at what
what's there um but essentially this is
meant to showcase um
how all of the data standards makes you
know allows you to um you know kind of
search by latitude and longitude because
those are formatted exactly the same and
so ultimately we're hoping to populate
this with more data sets and more
environments and hopefully hope that
it's going to be a useful resource for
everybody
and so this was a paper that was
published early last year that was
contributed to by many folks
within the microbiome space and i wanted
to just quickly share here that
so this figure is meant to show the
different environmental um
packages so if any of you are familiar
with the genomic standards consortiums
mixed s packages um they do break up the
environments in which microbiomes come
from by these um that are listed here on
the y-axis here so of course across the
human space then of course the the
broader environmental space too
and then on the x-axis here we're trying
to measure you know how compliant are
they with actually matching the package
that they're using to the environment
that they sampled and um the red here is
um to showcase you know those who
actually used it correctly and um you
can see across the board there's a lot
of variation across environments um it
looks like you know this is a little bit
of a sampling bias because we have a ton
of human data so um it does look like
you know maybe the human skin and
vaginal are a bit more compliant and
more familiar with the right package
versus some of the others it might be a
little bit more murky in terms of
knowing what to choose so
we can definitely do better in terms of
helping the community learn how to
properly use the right package and then
apply the standards as well
but yeah i will stop there and hand it
back to lisa
great thank you and now i realize that
we probably have a mixed audience here
so i'm going to give a brief
introduction to the human microbiome
and urinary microbiomes that we can all
be on the same page about the data that
we're talking about
so as many of you know humans are
complicated superorganisms that live in
a symbiotic relationship with many
different microbes that make up our
microbiomes
though there's some debate about the
actual numbers it's estimated that for
every single human cell we have we have
at least one possibly 10 microbial cells
and genetically speaking we have on the
order of 23 000 human genes but have
2-10 million microbial genes which
importantly change throughout our
lifetime
now these bacteria viruses and fungi are
all vital for human health they carry
out important biological functions such
as digesting nutrients and synthesizing
vitamins that we can't do on our own and
some such as lactobacillus play critical
role in maintaining health by making
parts of our body inhabitable by
pathogenic bacteria
thus this have been this has been a
large missing piece in knowledge that we
have about human biology as and is an
important factor to consider when we're
trying to study understand and treat
human disease
now research on the human microbiome has
been increasing in recent years and
associations have been found between the
human microbiome and several common
disorders such as inflammatory bowel
disease obesity diabetes heart disease
and even less obvious disorders such as
depression
now an important thing i would like to
point out is that many of these studies
have identified microbial associations
not a microbial cause of disease
this means that the microbiome is
altered in the disease state but it's
not clear if the microbiome is
responding to or causing disease and
this actually
can be quite challenging to get at
especially in complicated systems such
as humans
nevertheless these microbial communities
hold great potential to be used as
diagnostics or prognostics for human
disease
and may play a critical role in
developing personalized medicine
so all this research on the human
microbiome has made us rethink and
re-explore body sites and tissues that
we previously thought were several how
many of you have heard that urine is a
sterile biofluid in the absence of an
infection i'm sure most of you have
however is it really reasonable to think
that the bladder would be sterile at
least in women it's in very close
proximity to some of the most densely
populated niches in the human body that
there have to be something really
special going on to prevent it from
being colonized
and over the last 10 years several
researchers have challenged this dog
month and have identified that bladders
of most adults do have some level of
bacteria in the absence of any
clinically identifiable infection
this effort was started by linda
brubacher and alan wolf at loyola
university and has been supported by
work
from several other research groups
across the world now
now you may be wondering why there's
such a large scale explosion of
scientists investigating the microbiome
and it's primarily because we now have
better uh methods and techniques for
detecting these microbes
so earlier methods that studied the
relationship between microbes and human
health were highly dependent on
culturing techniques where we would take
a sample and plate it on some selective
media
and wait for colonies to start to
grow
now while this gave us really great
in-depth information about specific
bacteria such as uropathogenic e coli it
gave us a limited view since the
majority of the human associated
microbes we now know about don't grow
under these standard culture and
conditions
now there are several ways that we can
study the urobiome and each will address
different questions being asked and
generate different types of large data
sets
for this talk i'm primarily focusing on
sequence based studies but there are
several other ohmic types of
technologies that are important for
understanding a microbial niche
such as proteomics and metabolomics
these omics will similarly need careful
consideration about the associated
metadata when we're trying to apply them
to investigate the urobiome
so whole genome sequencing is a
technique where we isolate grow and
sequence microbes and we can do this
extensively to study the urobiome using
expanded quantitative urine culture that
was developed by alan wolf's group
this approach yields high quality
information but requires the microbe to
be grown in culture and isolated with
high purity to be successful
now there's community-based measures
such as shotgun metagenomics which
will sequence all the genomes of an
organism present in a given sample now
this will include the microbes we're
interested in such as bacteria fungi and
viruses but will also include the human
host dna which may be
much more abundant than the microbes
so this approach will give us in-depth
information about those organisms that
are present and also their genetic
content or their functional potential
however there are significant
limitations such as that host dna
contamination complexity and expense
and importantly the ideal use of this
technology to study the urobiome has not
been worked out thoroughly and only a
few studies have used this approach most
of which have used voided specimens
which are higher microbial biomass
than those sample directly from the
bladder
now another approach that's widely used
is marker gene sequencing where we
target and sequence a specific gene
to study bacteria we target the 16s rrna
gene and to target fungi
we can use another gene such as 18s or
ips
now commonly we only target a small
variable region or amplicon of that gene
though full length gene sequencing
approaches are becoming increasingly
common
this approach only provides taxonomic
information about
the targeted organism but does so at a
much greater depth and is much more
affordable than the shotgun metagenomics
approach
now importantly both the shotgun
metagenomics and marker gene sequencing
approaches do not require us to isolate
and grow the microbes in order to study
them so they hold great potential for
identifying and investigating microbial
communities directly from a patient or
research participant samples
all these studies
using sequence based technologies
generate large amounts of data
but that data needs to be processed and
essentially translated so we can
understand what it means biologically
and the ultimate goal
is to take these a t g's and c's and
generate a simple data table such as the
one displayed here where we have a list
of bacteria and a count of how many
times those bacteria occurred in each
sample
now once we have our data table we're
ready to continue on with our analysis
however if we don't have additional data
about these data we'll be at a complete
loss
this is where metadata or data about
data comes in
so metadata contains the context we need
to make sense of our data to be able to
summarize the variation of these
individual microbes
and how they associate with an outcome
of interest for example if we are
interested in differences between a
specific bacteria and individuals with a
disease compared to healthy controls
that don't have the disease we would
need to make sure that this the
information is captured to identify
which sample came from a healthy or
diseased individual in our metadata so
that we can make this comparison
so now move on to the data life cycle
so many of us know about the research
life cycle and the data life cycle is
very similar essentially once a
researcher has a compelling research
question and secures funding or other
means to address that question the data
life cycle will begin for a
comprehensive well-designed research
study
throughout the research study data will
be created processed analyzed and
ideally preserved accessed and reused
for future research which will inform
and generate new research questions thus
resetting the cycle
and typically a lot of effort goes into
this first part of the cycle especially
in human subjects research the first
part of the cycle deals with generating
and capturing the data which is
typically processed and analyzed to gain
biological or clinical insights
once the data are interpreted the
researchers typically prepare them for
public dissemination
to the research community through data
presentations at scientific meeting and
publishing in journal
and ideally the data would be preserved
so that others can access
and reuse this data
however there's often gaps in this
latter component of the data life cycle
that don't become apparent until someone
wants to reuse
the data that was created for an
additional
purpose
this other person can be someone
external to the research group a
research
a researcher within the research group
or as often as the case the researchers
future self
the purpose for data reuse
are quite limitless especially in the
omits age but typically it's for
something like a meta-analysis over
several different studies or to gain
preliminary data for grant or develop or
test new methodology or modeling
techniques that can lead to unique
insights about the data
now ideally data reuse should be
straightforward with a clear path
demonstrating how a researcher got
from the data sources to targets and
what steps occurred to generate and
process those data
now i'd like to take a poll and receive
your input if you have any relevant
experience so just give me one moment
here
so if you could um join
uh this poll by either scanning this qr
code or going to slido.com
and typing in 1
26754
and answer this question of whether
you've reused data from publicly
available sources
or not
so it looks like a lot of our audience
members do use
existing data some do not
so there is a bit of a mix which is what
i was hoping for
so great and
um i do see that some people are still
accessing which is great um so we do
have a bit of a mix where people have
and have not used um data from publicly
available sources
now those of you that have i would kind
of like you to describe that process in
one to three words
was it an easy process or
not so much
so there's a few responses
which are time consuming
hard to do in a reproducible way
someone encountered regulatory obstacles
and
others have found it messy and hard to
find the metadata or that the data that
they did find was not helpful
okay and it seems like those responses
are slowing down
so we'll go back to the presentation now
thank you for participating in that poll
so as the poll revealed data reuse is
hard and is not always straightforward
or intuitive as is illustrated by the
wanting chaotic paths between the data
sources and targets in this illustration
this can lead to data being inaccessible
not well documented and there can be a
lack of clarity in what the data
actually are and how they were generated
and much of these problems arise due to
gaps and
issues in that data life cycle
so for optimal data reuse ideally this
latter part of the data life cycle
would have data that has a standardized
format and to really work effectively
um the data actually needs to be both
human and machine readable and
unfortunately these um
this is also often where the problems uh
come from and this is what generates the
gaps in the data
life cycle and it creates issues with
data views
so one of the goals of the national
microbiome data collaborative is to
accomplish this by helping researchers
streamline these common gaps in the data
life cycle and towards this goal the
nmdc has been engaging with several
research communities to community to
communicate and adopt the use of data
standards to improve data reuse
and the ideal way to do this is to have
the needs for data preservation access
and reuse in mind when you start data
collection if the data are collected in
a way that uses data standards from the
beginning
this information will be much easier to
include along with the data upon um
submission to a repository which will
then ensure that the data preservation
and access components of this life cycle
are not missed and this will increase
and improve data views
so to improve the data lifecycle and
standardization we can use principles
from data management which
is increasingly becoming necessary as
studies are generating large complicated
data sets
now following data management best
practices includes being intentional
about the process of collecting storing
processing and protecting data as it is
being generated
and ideally data good data management
will naturally support data preservation
and the fair standards of making data
findable accessible interoperable and
reusable
now there's several benefits to
following
data management best practices and of
those the ones that really come to mind
are that data would be discoverable
accessible comparable and persistent
now the impact this can have for
individual researchers is actually quite
large it can really increase your
scientific exposure and help
to ensure that the work is appropriately
cited and referenced
and the impact can actually be
quantifiable and measurable especially
if there's a digital object identifier
associated with data products
so beyond the individual researcher the
best practices also enable better
science which has large benefits for the
ultimate goal of generating knowledge to
drive innovation and discovery
now specifically for your biome research
we need this knowledge and innovation to
really move the field forward to achieve
the ultimate goal which is to improve
health outcomes and clinical management
of patients that suffer lower urinary
tract symptoms that disrupt their daily
lives
now much of the data management comes
down to contextual information that we
collect about our data which is referred
to as metadata
so as i mentioned metadata
are the contextual data about data and
they let us know how to interpret the
data by providing the who what where
when and why about our data and this is
essential for preservation discovery
access and reuse of data
so there's several types of metadata and
today i'll mostly be talking about the
first two that are on the slide
which are both considered sample data
now this includes information about the
person who provides the sample
or that the sample was collected from
and also information about that physical
sample itself
now the several other components of
metadata that we won't be covering today
are nonetheless very important and this
includes information about how the data
was generated from the sample
how that information
was processed and then the final
data annotations for interpretation
so sample metadata includes information
about the phenotypic properties of the
individual that it was collected from
we typically have an identifier that we
use to identify a particular subject so
if they have multiple samples that are
collected we know that they all belong
to that specific individual we also want
to capture information about diseases or
if the participant belongs to a
particular
group of interest that is being studied
we also want to ensure that we are
capturing information
about potential confounding factors or
though that those that might influence
the microbiome such as diet or
antibiotic use essentially we want to
make sure we capture any vital
information that we need to perform our
statistical analyses at the end of the
study
now the sample data about the physical
sample also includes information about
when the sample was collected
what kind of sample it was
and typically we also have information
about
the body site that it came from
and other properties such as ph or
storage conditions
now in addition to knowing what kinds of
information we need to collect we need
to have standards to ensure that we're
using the same language and formatting
across individuals that are collecting
the data
as an example suppose we have data
that's being completed by two different
researchers now both these researchers
are
collecting the vital information that we
requested from them they're going to
collect a sample identifier information
about the type of sample and the
participants age
now you can see right off the bat
these two researchers used uh different
column names um in the information that
they're trying to
acquire
and this might seem minor but it can
cause a pretty large headache and even
misinterpretation of data down the line
for example when we review this data
several days or weeks or even maybe
months later will it be clear to us if
the sample id and id number are
referring both to the same thing what
about the sample type in sample origin
and then is the age
in that second table is that referring
to the age of the subject or the age of
the sample right so there's a little
lack of clarity here
and this can definitely cause confusion
so we can make sure that we're using
standardized column names across these
researchers to help harmonize the data
and um
have some better data hygiene
now if we look at the actual values or
the contents of these columns of these
columns in these data tables you'll see
that these two researchers are using a
little bit different notation
um they're being a little different in
their capitalization structure here so
we have a sample id that begins with a
lowercase c
and then we also have
the same number but the the c is a
capital c and it could be hard to
identify if these are supposed to mean
or refer to the same sample or not
especially if some time has passed
so we want to make sure that we're being
consistent and clear on how we're
capturing these individual cells
so now if we look at the
sample types that were collected again
we have differences in the languages
that are being used here the first
researcher is using terms such as clean
catch catheter and vaginal to describe
the samples and the second one is using
terms such as voided urine urine and
vaginal swab
now if this is if this data was um
submitted with sequencing data any
future researchers trying to find uh
data that pertains to urine samples they
would only be able to identify
the samples that were in the second
table and the clean catch and catheter
samples would not be represented whether
or not they were supposed to
so we need to make sure that we're being
very consistent in this terminology
and we may want to actually make sure
that outside of our own research group
we go to uh using standard terminology
that might be
in ontologies or structured vocabulary
so that we make sure that we're using
the same language that's using that's
used by other researchers in the field
now again if we look at the subject age
column you'll see that there's quite a
few differences in the formatting that
these two researchers are using one
person is just using numbers and the
other is using numbers and letters
one of the researchers is just using a
single number the other one has multiple
in this field
so again we want to make sure
that we are harmonizing things and being
consistent on how this information is
collected
all these little details ideally should
be worked out in the beginning of a
study as researchers are collecting the
data to minimize the efforts that are
needed and possible confusion for
misinterpretation later and these are
definitely essential to iron out before
we're sharing data
with the broader public
so if we standardize
the sample data it really will support
other researchers including our future
selves to be able to search and perform
discovery based on these types of values
that we captured
and it will make data more findable and
improve the ability for it to be reused
so now we're going to discuss some of
the microbial metadata community
standards that are currently in
existence
so the nmdc
wisely integrates utilizes and enhances
existing community-driven standards
and the ones that they primarily use are
listed here it's the minimum information
about any sequence standards or mix s
which are from the genomic standards
consortia
and they also use the gold or genome
online database
standards from the joint genome
institute and the envo environmental
ontology standards which are from the
open biological and biomedical ontology
foundry
so the nmdc derives their mandatory
metadata from these existing community
standards and here i have just a handful
of them uh listed from the mix s and
envo packages
um so with mixes we have
uh some information about sample
identifiers geographic location
and uh sample storage conditions and the
envo terms really revolve around
environmental um terms
so the mix s
standards are widely used and there are
several environmental packages and
checklists that are
available for specific microbiome
environments now these can be
incorporated
and are actually used by several
resources and public repositories such
as the sequence read archive or sra and
also the
ena
these packages have been around for
several years and have
have a set of unifying standards for
describing microbiome samples from the
environmental sample samples such as
soil and water and even human associated
samples
and the genomic standards consortium has
an extensive documentation on their
github
which i have linked here
um and they also have several formats of
uh how to
generate and
collect this information from excel
files to json formatted
formats as well
so the mixx checklists
are associated with the type of data
that was generated and these can be
combined with the environmental packages
for a specific research study so here
i'm just demonstrating that there's uh
the mix x checklist for genomes
metagenomes marker genes etc and you'd
want to make sure that you're selecting
the correct one for the type of data
that you generated
and you would combine that with the
environmental packages here um are 17 of
the packages that were
uh
available in mix x version five mix x
version six has recently come out and
those newer packages have not been
represented on this slide but
importantly for the eurobiome field i am
working with the genomic standards
consortium and also the research
community to generate a human eurobiome
mix x environmental package but it's
still under under development
um in the meantime there's several human
associated packages available that are
highlighted on the slide such as human
vaginal and the broad human associated
that
we can use as a starting point for
collecting our metadata
now each package has its own set of
several metadata fields and recommended
data structures
that were decided upon from community
input
they also have a set of mandatory fields
that were deemed essential by the
research community and specific for
that environment or package
and finally there are several shared
mandatory
terms that are shared across several
packages and these are the ones that the
nmdc
uses for their standards
importantly i'd like to mention that
in addition to the columns that are
present in a specified package you can
add additional columns if the
information you'd like to include about
your data is not captured in an existing
package that you choose ideally you
would look at other mixex packages first
to see if there's a similar term that
exists
so that the information can be somewhat
standardized but if it doesn't you're
not restricted
in only using their terms
so now i'm going to move on to the
environmental descriptor terms which are
mandatory and mix x um
and are required for submitting data to
the ncbi sequence read archive so
they're commonly used but i definitely
know i thought they were a little
confusing for human associated studies
since these terms really come from
environments so the envo ontology is
from the oboe foundry and it's a higher
hierarchical classification system for
classifying samples by environment
so one of these environmental
descriptors is the broad scale
environmental context and this term
should
come from the envo ontology which is
referenced on the slide as i have
demonstrated here you can see
um that you can select the biome
you would select a biome that the sample
originated from
um
and in this example
we're selecting the urban biome to
indicate that the sample originated from
people who spend the bulk of their time
in an urbanized area and if that's not
exactly what we need or we don't have
evidence that
the individuals in our study
spend most of their time in the
urbanized areas we'd want to use a more
generalized broader term that's above it
in this nested tree structure
now in addition to those broad terms
there's a local scale environmental
context which for these terms for human
associated microbiomes we'd actually
want to use uh uber
anatomy ontology or uber on which again
is linked at the bottom of this page and
here i have an example
of the tree structure
from an anatomical entity
and you can see that we can use the
terms lower urinary tract and if we have
a
specific catheter collected specimen we
could go more specific and say that that
sample came from the urinary bladder
and additionally there's environmental
medium terms which should also come from
the uber on ontology for human
associated microbiome studies and here i
have an example of the logical tree
structure for urine which indicates that
the data originated from a urine
specimen
so at this point i have introduced
several of the microbiome metadata
community standards and i've given some
examples of how they're used in
neurobiome research
now i'll review
the current status of these standards
and how we need to adapt them
which is a evolving and ongoing process
so the eurobiome research field is still
relatively young compared to other
microbiomes that have been studied for
decades and to effectively study the
microbiome we need expertise from
clinical specialists such as urologists
urogynecologists nephrologists and
pediatric urologists we also need to
make sure that we're capturing several
experts from biology such as
microbiologists and bacteriologists
and
virologists
and also the analytical sciences such as
chemistry biochemistry bioinformatics
and
statistics
so we need to make sure that we're all
working together and communicating
effectively
with each other to achieve the goals as
a community which is primarily to
improve the health care for patients
with low urinary tract disorders and
towards this goal the eurobiome research
community has begun to form standards
and consensus
to make sure that we're all educating
each other and this consensus statement
was published
in m systems last year
so now first and foremost
we must always keep in mind that
at some point the data that we have came
from a human subject so it may or may
not fall under the realm of human
subjects research depending on what data
we're using and what information was
collected so we need to make sure that
when we're sharing data we're paying
particular attention to
the rules of the institutional
review boards that oversee human
subjects research and that we make sure
we're very very very careful that we
only share de-identified data
and this means that there's definitely a
balance between being comprehensive and
also protecting privacy i know when i
look at some of the mandatory mix s
fields a lot of times i actually can't
share the information
that's required on those fields because
of the human protection
because the human protections that are
in place for the human subjects research
and
um the the big thing that i commonly
encounter is dates typically dates
cannot be shared uh just because they
might contain sensitive information that
may not be obvious to you or the
researcher
um
and often there are broad policies that
no dates can be shared um just kind of
as a blanket policy and this means that
any dates that we export need to be
either
uh have some sort of offset or be
generic such as just using a month and a
year only the same goes for location
location um particularly if it's tied to
the participant's home address cannot be
shared even in metadata and another one
that i commonly um see is age over 90
might not be obvious to everyone that
that could be sensitive information and
is often not terrible and there are
several others this is by no means
comprehensive
another particular point for urobiome
research is that the terminology we use
when investigating the microbiome
we need really need to start being very
uh consistent because it's really key
for communicating and interpreting
results and the literature is already
getting uh quite a bit murky with if
we're studying the urinary urine or
bladder microbiome and we need to make
sure that the community is agreeing on
definitions for these types of micro
microbiomes that we're studying which is
often tied to the sample type that we
collected
so now another issue that i've
encountered
in my research is that the terminology i
need to describe the diseases or
disorders that i'm studying
is not really accurately represented in
the recommended disease and phenotype
ontologies that are out there um here's
one example so i study urgency urinary
incontinence
or urge urinary incontinence and when i
try to find that in the existing
ontologies
i'm giving the i'm given the options of
either urinary incontinence or stress
urinary incontinence and stress urinary
incontinence is a very distinct um
different type of disorder and urinary
incontinence is really too broad so i'm
not able to accurately
uh capture urge urinary incontinence
which is then unfortunate for
future research because people
are unable to search and find samples
that are associated with that term
and similarly when i look up urinary
urgency
i receive this definition that
incorporates
incontinence but that's not really quite
correct because you can have urinary
urgency in the absence of incontinence
so again these are
you know issues with the existing
ontologies that we need to work as a
community to
fill these gaps and make sure that we're
accurately describing um and how the
terms available that we need to us
so many of the concepts and guidelines
that i just discussed have been
published in this durability consensus
paper by brubeck baker at all um that
was published last year um this work
came out of the eurobiome 2020
conference that was held prior to the
pandemic where several researchers in
the urobiome field from different
backgrounds met and discussed these
details to try to develop a consensus
for this field
and
importantly we have several tables about
terminology and then also
metadata that should be collected or
elements that should be collected as
part of your biome research as i'm
displaying here which is from the table
one and as you can see here we have a
lot of biological elements
such as age sex and antibiotic use and
we also indicated if we think they are
required or desired for eurobiome
research
and as you can see this maps to the
variables
that we kind of discussed in the mixed x
packages
and here you can see that there is a
in-depth description or definition and
then also recommendations for terms for
investigators to use
and as part of this manuscript we also
included
a template in the supplemental material
that can be downloaded and used by
researchers and my group has also been
working on a redcap version that's near
completion where researchers can use
this to capture
the data in a standardized form
and it's compatible with the mix x data
standards
so in conclusion i hope you learned
about metadata standards and
applications for eurobiome research if
you'd like to gain a practical hands-on
experience digging into these details of
metadata for your about research please
join the eurobiome metadata workshop on
may 11th
registration will have a chat so please
only register
if you plan on attending and register
early to make sure that you can secure
your spot
also the euro volume standards are still
in development so please join the
conversation if you're in this area of
research or if you have expertise that
you think you can contribute to this
area of research we do have a eurobiome
101 workshop
that's coming up
at the
oggs ayuga
meeting in june and we are looking
forward to having another eurobiome
conference in 2023
there's also a caribou connections
working group for eurobond research so
please get in touch with me and i can
put you in touch with um
those folks as well
so with that i'd like to thank all of
you
you